well did you know when I started was a
completely different set of tools then
then then today somehow you know I yet I
like to divide our profession in the DC
and AC just like history so bc's before
the computer AC is after a computer
before the computer was extremely an
intensively manual you know so of course
I grew up with a pencil and I suppose my
computer at the time and and so drawing
drawing drawing and the tools of drawing
well you know the usual ones you and
eventually then you graduate from the
tools when the work increases and you
start to drop by freehand as precise as
possible and as accurate as possible and
I was pretty good so for me one inch was
a particular length you know but in
centimeters or inches and which is kind
of important too because it gives you a
very good sense of dimension and
therefore a good sense of scale you know
scale is extremely important you know
and skill is not dimensions dimensions
are physical and scales are mental and
so without the knowledge of one you
can't get to the knowledge of the second
one you know in a sense then you know
then there was a lot of glue lot of
other materials you know pasting Upton
you know specifying type in losing type
and very long and tedious process
photostat machines faced up again you
know god what a life explain two-thirds
of my life for nothing email missions
then all of a sudden God said this
incredible thing which is the computer
that is the it's like God said sending
Jesus Christ is that kind of a thing you
know I don't believe in one or the other
but you know but I can't believe on the
computer and so that was the great
Redeemer
so throw away all other kind of tools
and all of a sudden you could do things
that we're taking a long time to do all
of a sudden you can do it and you can
see while you're doing it so that is a
very very very exciting thing not only
that but you could do things better than
ever in history you can also do think
Austin in history you know all the time
most of the people do worse things than
ever but good guys them make better
things than ever and so that is a great
tool to work and this is what what we
use all the time now see some medieval
as you can see he then I still use my
pencil you know and i'll use the
computer muscle for email and writing
and things like that and googling and
proper blood and checking the words you
know as you can imagine not be my first
language I have to check spelling all
the time and and then then I have you
know people working with me which are
very very literate in the computer and
so I can work behind them and save no
bigger little smaller yeah like this
yeah this is great this but try this
trident you know it's that kind of
operation but which is very funny you
know in a sense you cannot play the
piano by having by telling a pianist
what to do go a little more to the left
or to the right you know and the same is
with a computer really you have to play
yourself to get the most out of it but
you know so it is a nice takes a long
time to learn to you know so I don't
think at the time I had to really use it
in it in a good way
computer is really like a pencil you
know it used to be you know the
pensioner can do anything you want to
but you have to do it you know and the
signals better computer you can do
anything you want but you have to do it
you know it's a tool you know even when
it goes by itself it's a disaster
because it's a very seductive kind of
tool you know the pencil you leave it
there and if that doesn't do anything in
this is it it doesn't move by itself it
doesn't offer anything he is totally
submissive to you the computer least and
even by accident offers incredible
beautiful things and there are very
seductive and if you forget about so if
you don't have an idea to begin with
it's very easy to be seduced and that is
not the good use of the computer you
know so that is the way it goes